hey everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial in this video i'll be showing
you how to speed up your safari web
browser just a little bit faster
i won't be using website for this video
just for the purposes of people who
don't actually have webkit yet so i've
opened up safari and the first thing
that i can tell you guys is that you can
go to the history class history tab
and clear your history
the second thing that you can do is go
to the edit button and hit empty cachet
this will empty
saved webpages in safari's history
next thing
you can go to the edit tab and hit reset
safari
now you can choose which ones of these
tabs that will actually apply
but um it can close all safari windows
it will clear recent web searches i
unchecked remove autofill
because i actually use it
and i remove save names and passwords i
also uncheck that
but i left all the others checked and i
hit reset this reset and opened a new
safari window browser and that will make
safari much faster the last thing you
can do is open use private browsing so
when private browsing is turned web not
saved entry downloads are not saved
and they are automatically removed from
the downloads window
and autofill also isn't saved so nothing
is saved no cookies will be saved and no
information tracking spam malware
nothing will be saved when you're using
in private browsing so i do that and to
make sure you're still in one private
browsing hit the edit button and make
sure there's still a check next to that
so that is how
that is another way to make safari
faster a quick way to do a lot of these
things is to use the ccleaner tool that
i did a review on earlier
ccleaner does a lot of removing these
temporary internet files if you just run
the cleaner once you can see it removed
three megabytes of temporary files
roaming etc
um
the last thing you can do is if you're
on a really intensive website such as
maybe i went to youtube.com
and or let's say i just went to
myspace.com right
i would hit the develop button which i
also did a video on how to get
and i could disable images
so now i will go to myspace.com again
and there are much fewer images on the
page except for the advertisements i can
go to develop and disable styles
disable javascript and as you can see
this page is going to load extremely
simply but quite quickly so
that is another way of speeding it up if
you can always uh re click all of these
uh
styles and such to get these images back
so
those are just a few ways to increase
the speed of your safari web browsing
experience without actually switching to
webkit
and um i hope you found this tutorial
helpful if you have any other video
ideas for me just subscribe and uh give
me a link or a video idea and otherwise
thanks for watching peace